[Music]
on this monday night the blistering heat
wave baking europe
getting too hot to handle anywhere that
you have to stay in the sun for a long
time that's that's off limits the
transportation concerns and deadly
wildfires the feds pitching pollution
solutions the options to slash canada's
oil and gas emissions
chilling police body cam footage of the
uvalde massacre we got to get in there
he skipped the failed negotiation with
the gunman
and paying for their sins the catholic
church's plan to compensate abuse
victims
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight tracy tong
good evening and thank you for joining
us a heat wave is scorching parts of
western europe triggering wildfires in
portugal france and spain and forcing
tens of thousands of people to flee from
their homes
this train full of passengers in
northwest spain got stuck as vegetation
burned up in flames near the tracks
almost the entire country faces an
extreme fire risk and the uk which is
unprepared for the extreme heat is
struggling with sweltering temperatures
with the next few days forecast to get
even hotter our edmund shannon has our
top story tonight from london
this just doesn't feel very british a
head melting heat the rising mercury
felt by locals and tourists alike
it's not quite as humid as it is back
home when it's hot but there's no air
conditioning here which is what
surprises me the uk just isn't set up
for these types of temperatures the
school year goes well into july in some
buildings which just aren't designed for
the heat some schools have had to close
we can't expect much learning to go on
in this sort of heat is the frank
reality
one of london's main airports stopped
flights for hours while workers repaired
a section of melting runway
and train services have been delayed
over concerns tracks are buckling a
growing acceptance britain may need to
adapt to a new future we will learn over
the next 48 hours about how the rail
system copes with this kind of heat
which it wasn't built to cope with we
will learn about how we deal you know as
a community with heat and it does worry
me a lot and and my colleagues here in
the met office that this sort of
unprecedented heat could be a regular
occurrence by the end of the century
in southern europe the worries are also
more immediate
heat now blamed for hundreds of deaths
and bellowing wildfires that have killed
at least two people in spain
the country's prime minister saying it
shows that climate change kills
this man somehow survived running for
his life after trying to protect his
village from flames
thousands have had to flee their homes
in france too with local records being
broken across the country here within
the uk wales broke its all-time
temperature record on monday but on
tuesday we're expected to see the entire
uk break its record of 38.7 degrees and
a temperature of above 40 for the first
time on record redmond shannon global
news london
well scorching temperatures causing
problems across parts of canada as well
a wildfire close to linton bc a village
wiped out by flames last year is still
out of control it's one of dozens of
wildfires burning in british columbia
alberta and saskatchewan and in northern
manitoba heavy smoke hampered evacuation
efforts on the matthias cologne cree
nation
as jamie dahl reports that blaze is
burning less than a kilometer away from
homes
shrouded in a smoky orange hue with just
one bag of belongings strapped to their
backs an entire community is forced out
by a threatening and out of control
wildfire spanning 23 thousand hectares
everything was smokey we had to wipe
everything down and
get rid of that smell and some people
wanted to bring their dogs but they
weren't allowed leo sinclair his wife
and son among approximately 2 000 people
evacuated from the mathias colom cree
first nation in northern manitoba one of
dozens of fires burning in that province
there are no accessible roads here in
the summer so trains planes helicopters
all brought into the remote community
some people leaving in the dead of night
first day was all chaotic the evacuation
began thursday and only ended late
sunday virtually everyone is out of the
community and now we're supporting them
in hotels in winnipeg
brandon thompson and the paw i'm okay as
long as my songs nothing burns in
british columbia hot dry and windy
conditions are helping to fuel the fire
burning near the already fire ravaged
village of litton that place is
consuming just over 1700 hectares 132
firefighters on the ground and a fleet
of helicopters are working to prevent
further damage to the devastated area
while a cool and wet spring has been a
substantially slower start to fire
season in b.c this year the recent heat
is increasing the wildfire risk as right
now we are seeing that warm and drying
trend coming throughout the week
so we are seeing the potential of
smaller ignitions through those dried
grass and those dried valley bottoms
many of the fires currently burning in
bc and manitoba remain in the north and
the smoke is lingering there too
unfortunate for those living in remote
areas but city skies remain clear and so
far this summer the majority of
canadians are breathing easy
at least for now
jamie doll global news calgary
extreme heat warnings are also in place
across a large swath of texas and the
u.s central plains sparking concerns
about the electrical grid and millions
of hectares of crops
texans have been asked to voluntarily
reduce their electricity use to help
avoid rolling blackouts
with a series of days in the high 30s
farmers across much of the central u.s
say they're seeing drought-like
conditions developing quickly
and back on home soil the federal
government is proposing a cap on oil and
gas emissions by putting an industry
specific price on carbon
ottawa is aiming to cut greenhouse gases
by 42 across all sectors by 2030 to
reduce the devastating impacts global
warming is having on the environment
like those raging wildfires that are
becoming way too frequent
abigail beeman reports
the oil and gas sector is responsible
for nearly a third of all greenhouse gas
emissions in this country the number one
source until now there hadn't been a
plan for how the industry factors into
the government's push to net zero by
2050. this is a complex piece of policy
the government is opening consultations
looking at two options to drive down
emissions 42 percent by 2030 a cap and
trade system or a modified carbon tax
but no specifics are included on how
much carbon pricing could increase from
the 170 dollars per ton it will reach by
2030 or what a cap may look like what
we've said uh since the the election
last year is that we would cap that
current emissions current levels so is
it 2021 2022
i think that would be a reasonable
assumption there's not much specific
because there's a whole problem with it
if you impose too hard a cap you're
forcing industry to try and adapt too
quickly it may not be possible and what
happens then is
potentially companies just shut down
production the cap itself would focus on
emissions not production but oil
production is an even more sensitive
topic given russia's invasion of ukraine
and the world looking for other sources
of energy the canadian association of
petroleum producers warns the ideas
could be counterproductive to achieving
climate goals saying imposing an
emissions cap solely on canada's oil and
natural gas sector as the paper proposes
will likely drive energy investment into
other countries who may not share our
high environmental and human rights
standards we have to be walking and
chewing gum at the same time this
environmentalist wants to make sure
consultations don't slow down the other
emissions slashing projects underway and
she feels a tinkering with the carbon
tax would be too complicated especially
with some provincial opposition what did
this government promise to do with oil
and gas emissions they promised to cap
those emissions and make sure that they
declined and so i think the most
straightforward way to do that would be
by implementing a cap those who want to
weigh in on either option have until the
end of september to respond and the
government hopes to deliver a plan by
early next year
abigail beeman global news ottawa
brampton ontario mayor patrick brown
says he will be seeking another term in
office fresh off being disqualified from
the federal conservative leadership race
i've come to the conclusion that based
on what
the action's taken that would be
impossible to have a free and fair
election at this point when ballots have
already already been sent out
earlier this month brown was
disqualified from the running for leader
of the conservatives over an alleged
violation of elections canada financing
rules
brown accused the pierre polyev campaign
of pushing for his expulsion which the
polyeff camp denies
brampton's municipal election takes
place on october 24th
ballots are now out in the conservative
leadership race with the results
announced on september 10th
emergency departments are struggling to
provide essential care across the
country some forced to close yet again
over the weekend and while er delays
aren't a new issue in canada experts say
wait times and closures are climbing at
an unprecedented rate
as jamie marocca reports there is
growing concern canadians will be left
scrambling for help when they need it
the most
morgan lanigan and his wife kelly were
at their cottage in new brunswick when a
pain she was experiencing became so
severe they rushed her to the nearest
emergency room they basically said uh
we're at full we're at over capacity and
we can't we can't see you uh and that
the uh
you know the regional hospital er is
also over capacity as well so
that's when we
kind of had to face a really
critical moment at that point suffer or
drive an hour to fredericton where they
arrived to another full waiting room
from vancouver island to newfoundland
and labrador canadian hospitals have had
to turn patients away clawing back hours
and temporarily closing their doors
we've always viewed our work and our
careers being one that is available for
you 24 7. no matter what any time of day
however we're seeing that we're not able
to deliver on that promise anymore in
alberta there have been 19 disruptions
to emergency and ambulatory care
facilities since the beginning of june
the province's official opposition says
new data also shows ambulance response
times have worsened and red alerts where
there's no ambulances available have
increased in frequency the system has
been run far too lean for far too long
the alberta government says its system
is not collapsing but this toronto
emergency room doctor argues it already
has i see it with my own eyes but even
in the urban centers like where i work
the wait times are longer and and
patients families are having to make
difficult choices on sunday montreal
children's hospital was forced to turn
patients away due to overcrowding and in
bc four interior hospitals announced
temporary diversions i'm hearing now
that ambulance crews were unaware and
showed up with a patient on the
overnight shift and had to
after arriving at the hospital doors in
clearwater had to divert to kamloops
that's an hour and a half away no matter
where you end up er physicians are
warning there's likely to be a wait
there needs to be planning and us on the
front lines we can only do so much we
try to help as much as we can we lack
the power to coordinate the whole system
that health experts say will require the
attention of all levels of government
but many canadians don't have the luxury
of time for policy to catch up to
reality jamie morocco global news
toronto
a high level shake-up in ukraine's
government coming up why the president
has suspended two of his top advisers
ukrainian president vladimir zolensky
has suspended two members of his inner
circle and launched investigations into
his country's intelligence agency and
prosecution service over allegations of
russian collaborators in those
departments the shake-up comes as
russian forces have stepped up their
onslaught in eastern ukraine and as
russia's largest gas exporter is warning
european nations it can no longer
guarantee future supplies mike armstrong
reports
the surprise announcement came in a
televised speech sunday night vladimir
zelinski suspending two of the most
powerful people in his government
just last thursday irina benedictova was
representing ukraine in the hague
coordinating with other countries over
investigations into war crimes as
ukraine's prosecutor general benedictova
has been a high profile and vocal figure
she's been front and center the other
suspended official hasn't had quite the
same profile but he does have very close
ties to zielinski himself ivan bakinov
was the head of the sbu ukraine spy
agency but he and zolensky were
childhood friends and he ran zelinski's
presidential campaign
zolensky suspended the two saying
members of their agencies are suspected
of conspiring with russia he said there
are 651 cases of alleged treason and
collaboration being investigated clearly
the russians have been
building this capability they have tried
to undermine
the ukrainian government the ukrainian
state for a long time
now russia is applying a different
pressure on other european countries
this week russian gas exporter gazprom
sent out letters to several customers
declaring something called force measure
it means it won't be able to send as
much fuel as it was contracted to send
due to something out of its control it's
a sort of active god clause there is
fear russia could move to cut off
supplies completely countries are now
trying to refill storage sites before
winter and the heating season mike
armstrong global news
the police's point of view
ahead the body cam video from the uvalde
school mass shooting
a leading figure of the freedom convoy
movement has been released on bail
[Music]
pat king spent five months in an ottawa
jail for his role in leading the
protests that choked the city's downtown
core for weeks
king is facing a raft of criminal
charges in connection to those protests
including mischief intimidation and
obstructing police and in april he was
also charged with perjury and
obstruction of justice there is a
publication ban on the evidence and
reasons for the court's decision but
king will need to abide by multiple
conditions as part of his release
a new report into the uvalde school
shooting describes what's being called a
systematic breakdown highlighting how
the safeguards designed to protect
students failed
and newly released police body cam
footage shows the chaos of that horrific
day when 19 children and two teachers
were killed jackson prescott reports and
a warning some of the images in this
story are disturbing
almost immediately police came under
fire as they rushed into robb
elementary the moments that followed
descended into a chaotic uncoordinated
response we got to get in there
we got to get in there and just keep
shooting
we got to get in there police spent more
than an hour waiting for instructions as
nearly 400 officers descended on the
school
as bursts of gunfire erupted from a
classroom school district police chief
pete arendando even tried to negotiate
with the suspect
this could be peaceful
outside other officers rushed to break
windows and rescue students
no one breached the classroom until it
was too late if you know there is active
shooting active killing going on or
somebody is dying
the standard is
you have to continue to do something to
stop that killing or stop that dialing
the first report into the massacre found
officers put their own safety over that
of the innocent victims there was no
clear leadership no proper communication
they don't protect nothing their powers
the school itself had issues too poor
wi-fi delayed lockdown alerts no one
used the school intercom to communicate
the threat the police failed us the
school system failed us those failures
costed our son his life the report
concludes most of the victims died
within minutes but some could have been
saved if police had acted sooner
this devastating look at police actions
has left families wondering if anyone
will be held accountable for the
failures of that day
prosko global news washington
in florida the trial for the parkland
school shooter started today
family members of the 17 people shot and
killed at marjory stoneman douglas high
school in 2018 were at the courthouse
for opening statements
in october nicholas cruz who is now 23
years old pleaded guilty to 17 counts of
first degree murder
jurors will decide whether he is
sentenced to death or gets life in
prison without parole
and jury selection has started at the
trial of donald trump's former chief
strategist steve bannon is facing
charges of criminal contempt of congress
after initially defying a subpoena
issued by the committee investigating
the january 6th attack on the u.s
capitol
the trial is going ahead even though
earlier this month bannon notified the
committee he is now willing to testify
if he's found guilty he faces up to two
years behind bars
atoning for abuse next how the catholic
church plans to compensate victims
ahead of pope francis's visit to canada
next week the supreme court of
newfoundland and labrador has approved
the sale of 42 properties belonging to
the catholic church including 12
churches the money from the sale will be
used to settle legal claims by victims
of sexual and physical abuse at a
church-run orphanage as ross lord
reports the sale items contain rich
history and even papal connections
even decades after the systemic abuse of
boys at newfoundland's mount castle
orphanage accountability is slow at
nighttime they come to your bed i know i
won't describe it in detail compensating
more than 100 victims most of whom are
now elderly men will cost the catholic
church an estimated tens of millions of
dollars to raise the money church
leaders in saint john's are turning to
the real estate market in an update to
parishioners archbishop peter hunt said
42 properties are for sale including 12
churches and that only a few will
continue to be used as catholic churches
the archbishop called it an emotional
and distressing process the properties
being sold are worth an estimated 20
million dollars among them this grotto
in the community of flat rock where pope
john paul ii visited in 1984 kneeling to
pray and bestowing a special blessing on
the grotto but the big stunner is this
the province's most famous church the
basilica of saint john the baptist the
basilica has stood as a stately landmark
in saint john's since it was built
almost two centuries ago court documents
show the basilica will be sold to a
heritage foundation which promises to
preserve it what has happened here
seems to have been the best possible
resolution in that the basilica will
still be available
for the catholic community but the value
of the basilica will go towards
compensating survivors the catholic
church has had trouble following through
on promises church entities agreed to
raise 25 million dollars for residential
school survivors in canada then came up
with less than 4 million dollars
officials suggest dozens of other
newfoundland church properties could go
on the block promising they intend to
meet their legal obligations to victims
while restructuring their organization
in a positive way
ross lord global news
and that is global national for this
monday night i'm tracy tong tonight's
your canada is lower island cove
newfoundland and labrador thanks for
watching jeff semple will be at the
anchor desk tomorrow have a good night
[Music]